got a Critics Choice I'm the only
network show how did that amazing I mean
what wonderful company to be in with all
the great nominees and and I think to be
recognized by a group of people that day
in and day out are really watching for
nuanced stories and character and all
that it's it's deeply humbling you know
I'm just I'm happy to be here the
cliffhanger that no one saw coming
Naomi what will happen to Toby I mean
anything I mean I think if we've learned
anything especially from Jack who's dead
people can die
it happens in life but but I'm not I'm
not telling people that Toby is dead
it's we gotta wait the five or six weeks
to the see when will we find out what
happened to Jack I think I think it's
gonna be a ways off I think what is
gonna happen you're gonna forget about
it you're gonna get wrapped up in the
lives of Jack and Rebecca and the big
three and then when you've forgotten
that he's gone we're gonna hit you with
it and it's gonna it's gonna crush you
yeah it's gonna hurt it's gonna hurt
real bad I think you may be let off the
hook for a little while yes I do
I mean it's gonna crush me it's just
gonna crush
[Music]
you